what do Barbie and liquid nitrogen have
in common well they both help scientists
find the best way to clean lunar dust
off your spacesuit yeah the moon's dust
can be a real pain it's super tiny and
super sharp it can damage astronauts
equipment and their lungs too so
researchers dressed Barbie dolls up in
little tiny space suits similar to what
the NASA astronauts wear they covered
them with a substance similar to Moon
dust and then they blasted them with
liquid nitrogen the experiment was a
success not only did the liquid nitrogen
clear away 98 percent of the Dust it
didn't damage the suit and this isn't
Barbie's first brush with space last
year Mattel sent two of the Dolls up to
the ISS to try and encourage children to
get involved with stem
one small step for Barbie